[Musique]
effectivement le cambodge veut dans
l'eure en afrique de l'ouest
géographiquement dit m mais
politiquement
nous sommes en afrique centrale donc ça
veut dire nous sommes sous leurs ordres
guinée et le cameroun ont comme on
appelle souvent c'est une afrique en
miniature puisque et à tous les zones
agro écologiques
c'est le touran afrique ici au cameroun
dans les effets des changements
climatiques à ce manifeste selon les
zones agro-écologiques bénévoles
à chaque moment et art ça se prononce
dans les inondations dans les zones
côtiers et la sécheresse et les
inondations aussi dans la zone ça aide
donc avec les tel décor gérer les
maladies nouveau et tout ça d'aucuns le
changement climatique effectivement
présents cameroun il nous en souffrons
beaucoup
de manière politique si on veut parler
des idées politiques et je crois que au
niveau politique exemple édition il ya
les nous venons de terminer avec les
adn elle est révisée et il ya aussi
avec elle
le sait qu'on appelle ona l'observateur
national pour le changement climatique
et tout ça dans le coeur à ce qu'ils
pensaient les lois et à saint-éloi
liette secteur une réglementation en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique et
la protection l'argument donc si à ce
niveau là on peut dit elle elana la
conscience des changements climatiques
les discours politique est là il dit tu
es 2009 à copenhague mais la question et
c'est est-ce que sur le terrain
c'est visible parce que quand vous ne
gagnez le budget comme rooney et
que l'état et on n'accorde pas beaucoup
d'importance aux effets des changements
climatiques et c'est que il y à détroit
où cela manque de foncier ou bien cela
manque de l'éducation donc dans la
société civile nous essayons d des
pouvoirs une coordination
interministérielle pour que à cette
conscience du changement climatique dans
tous les secteurs du milieu du
gouvernement mais sinon au niveau des
paroles du discours les lois les
implémentations je crois que le cadre
est sur la bonne voie mais un parti sous
lequel la pauvre celui qui est et n'est
ce pas
cela pas fondu là ils n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts dans les faits il
est mené face du changement climatique
sont effectivement présents qu'en gros
et les gens la zone
et adc la caisse quelques mois ou bien
sinon quelques semaines qu'est le dos la
vie économique la capitale économique
étaient à peine cousin alain esnault
l'est donc aussi dans l'extrême-nord
l'externat soir c'est la sécheresse ou
les inondations s avec les lignes les
pertes de vies inutiles
docteur ça se voit partout et dans le
zone savane de savane c'est les effets
des changements climatiques et les les
saisons tu vois ce n'est pas aussi
constant dans à ceux qui donnent ce
qu'ils donnent des problèmes au présent
parce qu'ils ne savent même pas tant
s'aimer et qu'a récolté donc avec les
maladies les tests qui vient
donc c'est un peu partout comme rôle
avec beaucoup des conséquences socio
économiques
joaillier nous sommes dans un contexte
lourd si la politique africain ne prend
pas sur les changements climatiques
ce que on va tout perdre vous savez que
à ces moments même joe cameron s'est
engagé dans l'énergie renouvelable ce
qui viennent
idéologie l énergie et du logis mais si
on ne prend pas reprendre les
conséquences du changement climatique
qui s'est investie mans seront perdus et
jenny jones
limitation des phrases bien les gens
vont continuer a surpris et ce qui est
plus inquiétant c'est que ce n'est pas
ce qu'ils sont riches qui en souffrent
du changement climatique nous est fait
n'est pas du changement climatique mais
c'est tout les pauvres parce que la
volubilité n'est pas seulement étaient
prédisposés a été affectée par les
effets des changements climatiques
mais la capacité de se lever quand on
est tombé à cause des changements du
multi est ce que le cameroun est moins
pressé lever assez vite s'il est
bouleversée par le changement des effets
du changement climatique
ce sera la mission la pauvreté les fait
qu'augmenter
les agriculteurs n'arrivent pas gelé des
bouquets tout ça docteur si on ne prend
pas ça oscille dans les plans dans
chaque département ministériel
or cela une paix dans les problèmes
beaucoup de problèmes dans les années à
venir dont je pense que on doit
continuer avec l'éducation verticale et
horizontale
je veux dire par là et avec les
gouvernements et avec les populations et
tout ça nous venons de finir l'arrivée
zone où elle laissait ici aux comores et
il va falloir que les consultations
parce que les populations ne savent pas
de quoi il s'agit il apparaît que pour
qu'ils s'engagent bien et parfois la
queue que l'éducation et l'information
pour en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique je viens de sortie de réunion
où nous avons la délégation officielle
emmenée à vie et en train des faisselles
fait c'est l'union pour voir la position
commun du combo est compressé de la
société civile qu'a menées avec le
gouvernement pour le coversyl danse et
autant de choses que l'on continue à
faire si on veut sortir des crises crise
climatique
ça n'a pas changé quelque chose et je
vous remercie de m'avoir posé ces
questions vous le savez très bien que à
leur arrivée à paris en 2015 l'afrique
en général avait des
projets des initiatives
pour l'atténuation c'était une
initiative sous le nez sur les énergies
renouvelables
est tous là pour l'adaptation et avaient
l'initiative sur l'adaptation africain
d'un étang à paris l'inasti
l'initiative de l'énergie a eu 7 g
engouement des pays développés parce que
vous
vous voyez à pied ça cette initiative
pourtant l'adaptation qui est aussi un
portable pour nous est que notre
priorité n'a pas usé ses jardins demain
dans à la fin même l'initiative pour
l'énergie renouvelable n'a pas suivi les
principes de gouvernance qu'ils avaient
qu'est-ce qui était posée dès le début
dans la société civile a été écartée
même c'est un pays reprenne gervais
parce que le nombre connaissait très
bien ce que je suis en 2010 ont supporté
le livre politique africaine pour
arracher cette initiative qui est un
mythe initiative populaire à l'afrique
discuter sur le quai avec le peuple
africain mais à la fin on en sommes nous
où en sommes nous avec cette initiative
c'est pourtant les déclarations et qu'on
a en main souvent à la fin rien à
regretter chez nous sous le financement
climatique est ce que le cameroun a eu
beaucoup d'argent 0 on n'a pas encore eu
ça ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas
de projet en âne pour les projets en
asie mais là les conditions et tout ça
sans seront divisés mais je pose la
question de savoir qui a créé ce
problème c'est les pays développés qui
ont créé ces problèmes on sait est ce
que les pays en voie de développement
qui souffrent de ce problème
doit faire la mendicité ou avant cet
argent sa ville je viens à nous comme
doigt parce que c'est la panique avant
cause d un problème il faut qu'on le
sache l'article 9 de l'attique l'accord
de paris elle est suffisamment clair
tout ça et que l'agent pour le
changement climatique soit pour
l'atténuation et l'adaptation d'un venir
des pays du nord pour développer un
nouvel ep avoir dignement surtout que
l'africa viendra à elle de circonstance
et spéciaux dont est ce qu'on prend
encore 0 on n'arrive pas à joindre les
deux bouts dans tous les pays j'avais
dit dans presque tous les pays africains
il faut qu'on le sache et que ce n'est
pas une question de l'aide et à pas mais
le financement climatique doit et que
les nouveaux et additionnels
dans ses sacoches sommes en train de se
battre pour que sa soeur a conduit comme
ça même si c'est le discours depuis
copenhague qui jusqu'aujourd'hui est en
assez des discours et bon discours car
les gens se sent à l'aise et pc pour
lancer mais à la fin où est l'argent les
500 millions de dollars ou bien ça
milliards de dollars il dit d'ici 2020
où en sommes-nous avec ça
si on n'arrive pas à fait ça c'est ce
qu'il a fait et quand ça sera à nous non
c'est ça qui est difficile je crois que
on est un peu frustré à mais ces
négociations sur le changement
climatique est faux que en charge la
méthode
nous attendons nous pensons que kobe
disney va causer à
ouvrir comme on dit chez nous à ouvrir
la porte pour qu'en voici qu'il allait
gagner
vous voyez le changement climatique est
avec nous et nous en afrique on dit
toujours que celui-ci une urgence il
mais il va falloir qu'on fasse des
choses qui comme restaurer ces
changements climatiques et même les
effets néfastes mais on dans les
discussions on n'est pas pressé ce n'est
pas urgent mais quand le coville a
touché tout le monde l'argent est sorti
d'une part on a mobilisé comme bien des
dollars
dont vous voyez c'est le manque de
volonté à tous les niveaux kinki qui ne
causent problème ici dans le monde ce
n'est pas le manque de moyens on a
toujours dit
le
co vite et comme une cause de sa magie
mais le changement climatique reste le
marathon combatu fine et même on est
dans une serre bateau les leurs on
appelle ça pas le titanic et les vrais
que les avoirs du mans qui sont dans le
kabyle en bas son joli suffit déjà
décelé colmant mais ceux qui sont là en
gros ça veut dire les pays développés
qui sont en train de boire le champagne
et faire la fête c'est la manne tout le
monde bat dessins dont il m'a parlé
comme prendre ça comme ça comme il nous
a montré qu' on le prépare avec la
l'inter et il faut que l'on prend sa
cible dans tout le fardeau ou bien venu
te souhaite pour commun si ce que les
gens me vient à l'esprit
on commence déjà dit la vérité
sincèrement et prendre les engagements
qu'on va faire quelque chose j'essaie de
manière saine c'est
l'ailé les positions politiques
économiques là on va mettre ça d'écouté
je gardais l'humanité en face on dit on
va changer la chanson peut-être est
arrivé à présent mais sinon on continue
à presser quand l'engin de verre ou de
ce qu'on a fait pendant 26 août en temps
ça ne va pas aboutir à quelque chose et
le mans va couler
[Musique]